states are the laboratories of democracy
and here in my home state of Kansas a
conservative experiment conducted by mad
scientists / governor Sam Brownback has
spawned teenage politician
my story begins in my beautiful home
state of Kansas
wait that's Kansas growing up my family
would tell me scary stories about the
state's history of moderate Republican
politicians but seven years ago a
governor named sam Brownback bravely
introduced extreme far-right policies
and most importantly a ton of tax
cuts kind of like president Trump's tax
cuts
Brownback's policies were dubbed the
conservative experiment you know we'll
see how it works we'll have a real live
experiment what happened next was the
state's revenue dropped by nearly 700
million dollars probably because over
300,000 businesses were able to stop
paying taxes entirely and sure the media
made it sound like a horror movie but
the experiment was exciting and shook
things up eliminating income taxes on
small businesses it's like a shot of
adrenaline straight into the heart yes
it was such a success that Brownback
resigned now he works for Trump in the
indispensable role of ambassador for
religious freedom
with an election looming in November
Kansas could now slip into the dangerous
hands of a Democrat or even worse a
moderate Republican or even worser a
teenager I'm 17 and I'm running for
governor since no one in Kansas ever
thought to set age restrictions for
governor
there are now six teams running and I
sat down with a few of them to have a
serious conversation about their
campaigns so adorable you look like you
ever seen those etrade commercial where
the babies are like talking and they're
like they sound like adults with their
babies I appreciate how much of an
interest are taking in our age what I'd
really like to talked about is my
platform because all of us are serious
candidates in this race it's so cute
when young people have opinions why
would I want to hear what these kids
have to say adults have been nailing it
case in point duh Sam Brownback the
Brownback administration in my view has
been one of the most disastrous
I guess political eras and in the
history of the state of Kansas
you guys probably hate the way Kansas is
being run right now because you're all
liberals right young people are always
liberals I'm a conservative with
traditional Republican values I'm
probably the most moderate Republican or
really even candidate in this race okay
you like Trump I'm anti Trump it feels
like they're trying to reanimate dead
ideas the current National Republican
Party and they passed a tax policy that
increased the deficit over a trillion
dollars I wanted to be a Republican that
fought for you know fiscal conservatism
or rejected Brownback's ideas of what I
consider fiscal recklessness it's just
so hard for me to keep up with like all
of these teen words you know it's like
on fleek fiscal recklessness this is all
wrong our state is in a bad position we
need to return to sanity bipartisanship
centrist exchange of value transparency
instead of moving left or right let's
move forward let's meet in the middle
no no Kansas doesn't belong in the
middle
Brownback's experiment began as a dairy
procedure to remove malignant taxes but
maybe he'd inadvertently spawned a
moderate pathogen causing young people
to seek compromise I needed to talk to a
real Republican and adults oh it is so
nice to be sitting and talking with
someone my age well you're not my age
obviously older but that's incredibly
impolite this is Republican state
representative Stephanie Clayton
hopefully she could reassure me that
this centrist ideology hadn't spread to
the state capitol I would compare myself
ideologically to President Eisenhower oh
okay so like you want to be on a coin no
that's not what that means I think it's
good for anyone for any political
perspective to be moderate that's the
kind of republicanism that I stand for
oh dear God
this plague of moderates was spreading
like the clap please clap I had to get
the hell out of there it was all
starting to make sense in response to
the Brownback years moderates defeated
eight incumbent state senators and
eleven conservative House members and
now moderate Republicans make up roughly
one-third of the state government
meaning this disease is multiplying and
I needed to protect myself
mom we have to leave campus do you want
to stay for dinner first yeah I can you
come away you guys haven't I
okay after some kickass Thai food I
realize I had to abandon my family and
my home but before I did I reunited with
patient zero Tyler and being the
sensible role model that I am I tried to
save him from politics you don't want to
get that I'm alright this dweeb was a
lost cause
besides Kansas was an isolated petri
dish with no similarities to the rest of
the country so I had no reason to worry
about this plague spreading nationally I
absolutely see similarities between the
Trump tax cuts in the Merrimac tax cuts
Kansas is a fair warning to all the
other states a nation into the national
government as well we can't follow in
the steps of the Brownback
administration so you're saying that
America is gonna be following in the
footsteps of Kansas yeah so that means
more child governors
[Music]